there was a guy messaged me he's like
dude I'm doing my my morning routine
he's like and I have a coal plunge a red
light sauna I ground outside and then I
do my gratitude Journal it was taking
him like 3 hours to get his routine done
or whatever in the morning and I was
like you know you could just not do that
and work for 3 more hours every day and
I was like I'll bet you'll make more
money and so I think there's a lot of
superstition right especially in The
Entrepreneur Space around routine as
like if I don't get my morning routine
and I'm just useless and I'm like man
I'd love to compete against you cuz like
you have one bad night of sleep and
you're I was like success doesn't
really care